me duele respirar fue el último grito de
la adolescente álvaro conrado antes de
ser asesinado por la policía
nicaragüense durante el estallido social
antigubernamental en 2018 cuatro años
después su familia reclama justicia
todavía no hay un responsable de su
muerte nosotros pedimos justicia
de montecchia queremos saber la verdad
de lo de los acontecimientos en ese día
álvaro fue uno de los primeros heridos
de muerte porque fue herido a
aproximadamente como las once y media de
la mañana verdad entonces queremos este
la verdad y justicia en 2018 miles de
nicaragüenses salieron masivamente a las
calles de todo el país en contra de una
reforma del sistema de salud propuesta
por el ejecutivo de daniel ortega
durante cinco meses nicaragua se
paralizó las autoridades sandinistas
respondieron con una brutal represión
contra los manifestantes que dejó al
menos 355 muertos cientos de detenidos y
más de 100.000 exiliados según la
comisión interamericana
hechos humanos justo rodríguez un
agricultor de 69 años pasó ocho meses en
prisión donde enfermo y ahora sobrevive
postrado en una cama llegando adelante
pero por qué me llevaron ahí me trajeron
todo chapa
no me dieron en
el suspiro agónico del estudiante sigue
resonando en el país en noviembre de
2021 ortega fue reelegido en el cargo en
unos comicios sin garantías democráticas
y con la gran parte de la oposición en
el exilio o presos más de 100 críticos
están en la cárcel en ese momento álvaro
conrado le dolía respirar porque una
bala había atravesado su garganta en
este momento los nicaragüenses
continuamos siendo atravesado por el
dolor por el llanto por las lágrimas
por el sufrimiento
ahí hay personas que que todavía no han
podido sanar ese dolor las
organizaciones de derechos humanos
denuncia que el gobierno nicaragüense
sigue tratando de silenciar las voces
críticas y se han prohibido las
conmemoraciones por el aniversario del
levantamiento social